these bright drops seem to be playing a  lively game of tag the drops are just  water and food coloring of which a main  ingredient is propylene glycol drops of  different colors contain different  amounts as it turns out complicated  interactions between water vapor and  surface tension caused the drops to  chase each other as two nearby drops  start to evaporate the space between  them has higher humidity so they each  evaporate less water on that side higher  humidity also means greater surface  tension which pulls the drops together  when the drops get so close they can  almost touch things get really  interesting propylene glycol has a lower  surface tension than water so of two  differently colored drops one will have  higher surface tension than the other  that pushes it away the other drop  follows and the chase is on based on  this discovery researchers have created  fluid machines that can drive the dots  around courses and sort them by color or  concentration